she's dazzled audiences in salina a
wedding planner and made in Manhattan
welcome Jennifer Lopez
question who can build anything from
mole hills to mountains prehistoric
caves to futuristic condominiums answer
the art director what you see on your
screen is dictated by what an art
director and his or her set dressers
prepare for the camera so here are the
nominees for achievement in art
direction
john mayer for the art direction and
board and sim for the set decoration of
chicago
Felipe Fernandez Del Paso for the art
direction and Honya Robledo Marie set
decoration of real Dante Ferretti for
the art direction and Francesca lo
Schiavo for the set decoration of Gangs
of New York grant major for the art
direction and Dan henna and Allen Leigh
for the set decoration of the Lord of
the Rings the two towers Dennis Gassner
for the art direction and Nancy Hague
for the set decoration of Road to
Perdition and the Oscar goes to John
Mayer for Chicago and set decoration
Gordon
this is the first Academy Award for John
Mayer and Gordon sim Mayer was nominated
in 1998 for Elizabeth
well this is just fantastic and as you
can see we made so many wonderful
friends on Chicago it was just one of
the best experiences we ever had yes and
that really came down to Rob Marshall
our director Rob thank you for bringing
us along on this amazing journey we have
to thank our crews everyone in the art
department set decoration Department
construction paint props
it was a huge collaborative effort and
we share this with all of you
I just want to thank John Myers so much
he's a wonderful creative man to work
with was just so thrilling thing if we
could thank our family and friends who
are watching all over the world thank
you very much Cheers
that was Jennifer Lopez or as the kids
today call her J Pez she's been married
twice and divorced five times now that
is a good lawyer